your surgeon may perform laparoscopic lysis of adhesions or tziolis is to wash sullen pica to remove scar tissue from your abdominal organs usually the surfaces of your abdominal organs are slippery and move easily over one another as you go about your activities
daily if you have bands of scar tissue in your abdomen called adhesions your abdominal organs will stick to each other or to the abdominal wall these adhesions can cause a bowel obstruction by narrowing your intestines or twisting or pulling them out of place blocking them partially or completely
to food or stool moving through them if you are female adhesions can cause infertility by twisting or pulling the fallopian tubes out of place partially or completely blocking the path of fertilized eggs to the uterus instead
where the baby can grow and develop the most common cause
n of abdominal adhesions is abdominal surgery other causes can be abdominal infections such as peritonitis inflammatory conditions such as abdominal appendicitis or radiation prior to the procedure you will be given a general anesthetic that will put you to sleep your surgeon will inject gas into your abdomen to expand the
abdominal cavity which will make it easier to see the internal structures your surgeon will then make a small incision to access the inside of your abdomen he or she will insert a laparoscope containing a flashlight a camera and a magnifying device the laparoscope will project images on the tv screen
to guide your surgeon's work after examining the abdominal cavity your surgeon will make three or four small incisions in your abdomen through which surgical instruments will pass with the help of these instruments your surgeon will cut the adhesions to free the organs from each other
or
Once all the adhesions are broken down
your surgeon will remove the
laparoscopic instruments and close
the incisions with stitches
after your procedure you will be followed
up in the recovery room
you may go home the same day or
stay in the hospital for up to three
days to help your recovery
keep the incision area clean and
dry take pain medication
as directed by your doctor
avoid heavy lifting and do not
drink carbonated beverages for 2 days